>>> SNOW RATED MAR-A-LAGO WITH
THE FEDS AND NOW HE'S GOT A
TASTE WITH HIS OWN MEDS. THAT'S
GOOD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> STOP IT. YOU ARE BITING INTO
THE TIME. THE WHITE HOUSE ADMITS
MORE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE
FOUND AND THIS TIME AT ONE OF
BIDEN'S HOMES IN DELAWARE AND IN
HIS GARAGE. IT IS COOL BECAUSE
HIS GARAGE IS TOTALLY LOCKED.
>> CLASSIFIED MATERIAL NEXT TO
YOUR CORVETTE? WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING?
>> LET ME -- AS I SAID EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND BY THE WAY, MY
CORVETTE IS IN A LOCKED GARAGE.
IT IS NOT LIKE IT IS SITTING OUT
IN THE STREET.
>> WHY WOULD YOU PUT IN THE A
LOCKED GARAGE.
>> WELL>> WELL, AS WELL AS MY .
>> BY THE WAY, IT IS ALSO A
CORVETTE.
>> ALL RIGHT, VIAGRA COMMERCIAL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT IS ALL GOOD, NO ONE EVER
BROKEN INTO A LOCKED GARAGE
BEFORE. THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE. IT IS
NOT LIKE PEOPLE LEAVE THAT GIANT
GARAGE DOOR OPEN FROM TIME TO
TIME LIKE WHEN THEY GET THAT
CORVETTE OUT. YOU KNOW I AM
THINKING WE SHOULD STORE OR
NUCLEAR BOMBS THERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> MERRICK GARLAND ANNOUNCED THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS APPOINTING
A SPECIAL COUNSEL WHETHER THE
WHITE HOUSE, BIDEN MISHANDLED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> LET THE PROCESS CONTINUE. IT
IS AN ONGOING PROCESS. THERE IS
AN ONGOING PROCESS. THIS IS ALL
PART OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PROCESS AS PART OF THAT PROCESS.
SAID THERE WAS A PROCESS
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS. WE JUST
LAID OUT THE PROCESS THAT WAS
TAKEN.
THAT'S THE PROCESS.
>
>>
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> JUST TRUST THE PROCESS WHICH
IS WHAT I TOLD JANET YELLEN WHEN
I GAVE HER THAT HAIRCUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> NO
>> NOW -- OBVIOU
HOUSE IS GOING TO DEFLECT AND
DEFEND OH, THEY WERE NOT IN A
SECURE LOCATION OR THE DOOR WAS
NOT LOCKED. HE DIDN'T KNOW HE
WAS VICE PRESIDENT. IT IS NO
SURPRISE THE MEDIA IS ON BOARD
WITH THAT, RIGHT, JOY?
>> THERE IS DIFFERENCES IN WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> YES.
>> SO NOT GOOD.
>> WE ALL KNOW THAT TRUMP IS AS
LIAR AND A THIEF, YOU KNOW? WE
KNOW THAT
KNOW TH
KNOW THA
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SO, IT IS NOT THAT BIG OF A
JUMP TO SAY HE OBSTRUCTED AND HE
LIED. WE DON'T THINK BIDEN IS A
LIAR OR A THIEF SO WE GIVE HIM
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN A LUCKIER
PERSON THAN DONALD TRUMP.
>> TRANSLATION, IF I KEEP
SHIELDING FOR BIDEN, THEY KEEP
FEEDING ME PUDDING. FUN FACT,
HER DEFENSE REQUIRES A SPECIAL
MICROPHONE SO WE CAN HEAR JOY
TALKING OUT OF HER ASS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT IT
WAS FOUND AT THE PEN BIDE
BIDEN/HUNTER.
>> BEN CARSON COULD NOT SEPARATE
THOSE TWO. AFTER THE CENTER
OPENS, THE SCHOOL RAISED
MILLIONS. I AM SURE IT WAS NOT A
KICK BACK, RIGHT, JOE?
>> YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> COME ON, I CAN'T DEAL WITH IT
RIGHT NOW. I CAN'T READING THOSE
CLASSIFIED STUFF WITHOUT ANY
READING GLASSES. I MAY HAVE A
CLASSIFIED IN THERE BUT I DIDN'T
HAVES ONE SECRET, NO TOP SECRET.
I DEFINITELY DIDN'T HAVE
THAT -- CROSS MY HEART OR HOPE
TO DIE OR STICK A NEEDLE IN MY
EYE. I DON'T EVEN DO THAT
ANYMORE. I USED TO. YOU KNOW
WHOSE EYES I STUCK A NEEDLE IN?
CORN POP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>
TYRUS, DO YOU THINK BIDEN WAS
RECEIVING THE SAME TREATMENT
TRUMP WAS GIVEN?
>>
SURE, 1,000 %. WE CAN'T
COMPARE TO TWO. HE WAS AS VP.
THEY'RE ACTING LIKE HE BROUGHT
THEM HOME LAST WEEKEND. WAS
THERE ANOTHER PRESIDENT IN
BETWEEN THE TIME HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT AND NOW SO THAT'S AT
LEAST FOUR YEARS AND PLUS THE
YEAR. HE HAD THESE FOR ALMOST
SIX YEARS AND EVERYONE IS ACTING
LIKE IT WAS LAST WEEK. DOES THAT
KIND OF MEAN SOMETHING? AND NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT IS COMING OUT
AND LITERALLY, AND LITERALLY
WHILE SHE WAS GIVING A SPEECH
EXPLAINING THE FIRST ONE AND HIS
SPEECH ARE TOUGH TO FOLLOW BUT
HE WAS SPECIFIC THAT IT WAS JUST
ONE THING. AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCREEN WHILE HE WAS GIVING THE
SPEECH, THE SECOND BATCH WAS
FOUND
FOUND. AND TODAY
EXPLAINING THE SECOND BATCH, THE
THIRD BATCH WAS FOUND. THE ONLY
DEFENSE I WILL HAVE FOR HIM IS I
GET IT. HIDING STUFF IN YOUR CAR
IS FOR MARRIED MEN THAT ARE
SAFE. IT IS WHERE WE KEEP THINGS
WE DON'T WANT HER TO KNOW ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY WE KEEP OUR CAR JUST
DIRTY ENOUGH TO WHERE WE ALWAYS
TAKE HERS. SHE WILL GO TO YOUR
CAR, OH, THE FRONT SEAT IS FULL
OF COFFEE CUPS, I AM NOT GOING
TO GET IN THERE. JUST TAKE MY
CAR. YOU ARE RIGHT, DEAR. AND
PROBABLY WHAT HAPPENS, OH,
JOSEPH, I WANT TO CLEAN THE
CORVETTE. OH, I WILL CLEAN IT
OUT. YOUR CAR IS YOUR SAFE. I
GET IT.
>> THIS IS HILARIOUS. WHAT'S SO
GREAT ABOUT THIS AND NOT SO MUCH
ABOUT THE DOCUMENT BUT HE WAS
SUCH A SELF-RIGHTEOUS ASS ABOUT
TRUMP AND NOW HE'S GETTING THE
PAY BACK HE DESERVES.
>> CAN I POINT OUT ONE SMALL
THING THAT IN ALL OF THIS, THE
PEN/BIDEN CENTER, HE WAS THE
BENJAMIN FRANKLIN, PRESIDENTIAL
PRACTICE PROFESSOR. BEN
FRANKLIN, JOE BIDEN? I DON'T
THINK SO.
>> ONE INVENTED ELECTRICITY AND
THE OTHER ONE CAUSES IT WHEN HE
RUBS HIS HAND.
>> I AM HELPING IT, YEAH?
>> THEY LIKED IT.
>> IT IS SAD BECAUSE IT IS TRUE.
>> I HAVE TO SAY KAT, DO YOU
THINK HIM INPUTTING THESE
DOCUMENTS IN HIS CORVETTE HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH HIS OIL
CANCER?
>> YEAH,
>> YEA>> YEAH,
A CORVETTE WHEN HE HAD OIL
CANCER. HE REALLY WAS RAISED BY
PUERTO RICAN AND HE WAS REALLY
JEWISH AND ALL THE STUFF HE SAID
LIKE -- SHUT UP. THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES. THEY DIDN'T SAY
HEY, WE FOUND THESE. TRUMP
DIDN'T DO THAT. HERE IS THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN BIDEN AND
TRUMP AND I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO BE AN ARTICLE ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES. IT WAS LIMITED TO
ALL THE WAYS AND DIFFERENCES
MADE BIDEN LOOKED BETTER THAN
TRUMP. RATHER THAN HEY, THE
THING WE SHOULD BE PISSED OFF
ABOUT IS ALL OF US SHOULD BE
PISSED. THEY FOUND ATE WEEK
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS AND WE DON'T
FIND ABOUT IT UNTIL NOW. I DON'T
CARE WHO YOU ARE, YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO VOTE WITH AS MUCH
INFORMATION THAT YOU CAN,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOUR PARTY
IS. EVERYONE SHOULD BE PISSED
OFF ABOUT THAT AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE IGNORING THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>
DO YOU THINK THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS JUST FOR SHOW?
>> PROBABLY. THEY HAVE TO MAKE
IT LIKE THEY WOULD DO WHAT THEY
DID FOR TRUMP. THEY DID NOT RAID
HIS GARAGE, DID THEY? THIS WAS
ALL A VOLUNTARY EPISODE BASED ON
THE FACT THAT HE HAD BEEN
CAUGHT. I AM STRUCK BY THE FACT
THAT IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE LEAGUE
TODAY
TODAY. THE UNIVE
PENNSYLVANIA THOUGHT IT WAS AN
IDEAL TO GIVE -- YOU LOOK AT THE
E-MAILS THAT CAME OUT OF
HUNTER'S LAPTOP. WHAT DID THEY
DO? THEY RAISE ALMOST
$100 MILLION FROM CHINESE
SOURCES WHEN JOE BIDEN SHOWED
UP. WHAT MAY THOSE DOCUMENTS BE
FOR? YOU RAISED A RIGHT POINT AT
THE BEGINNING. DONALD TRUMP WAS
THE PRESIDENT HAVING THE POWER
TO DECLASSIFY. JOE BIDEN WAS
NOT. THIS SHOULD BE A REAL
PROBLEM. THE TIMING IS THE
STORY. DO THE DEMS WANT HIM OUT?
>> YEAH, IT COULD ALL BE FROM
THE DEMS.
>> I MADE THE MISTAKE, YOU HEARD
ME AND I THINK IT WAS ON TUESDAY
WHERE I SAID KAMALA, DO
SOMETHING.
>> SHE DID IT.
>> APPARENTLY SHE WATCHES THE
SHOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S ALL SHE DOES.
>> THAT'S TRUE.